yes yes what's up my name's samuel elite
i'm a property investor i've been
investing successfully in property now
for over 10 years and in this video i'm
gonna give you
the five things that you need to do to
become successful in property so if
you're starting out right now like i was
when i was a teenager starting out in
property
i wish i'd known these five things when
i started out so you might wonder why
i'm walking around a hotel room and why
i'm so ridiculously excited so i am
going to give you the five things you
need to become successful in property
but why i'm in a hotel room is because
right now i'm waiting for my wife to get
ready it's our fifth
year anniversary we're in paris she's
taking a little bit of time so i thought
i'd
do this video while i wait for her hey
amanda hey she's looking fantastic come
on let me see your face let me see your
face
she's looking fantastic i think you look
about about almost ready to go so i'm
gonna make this video real quick
we're hungry uh also i'm really excited
to just find out i'm an uncle my
sister tiffany gave birth to another uh
boy last night so massive
congratulations i'm just excited i'm
happy
i'm in paris you might be able to see
right here here we go
there is the eiffel tower fantastic
so um beautiful day beautiful weather
listen the first thing
first thing is you need to get goals in
fact every one of these things five
things
every one of them starts with a g okay
starts with a g so first thing is
you've got to get goals and why you need
goals is because what i've realized is
property investing is actually a
vehicle to just achieve what you want to
achieve and if you're not
sure on your goals you just think i just
want to be successful in property if you
haven't got a strong reason
why it's not going to happen people talk
about willpower you need to get
willpower you need to
psych yourself up you don't need
willpower what you need is you need
y power you need a strong burning reason
so if you're watching this video
you want to be successful in property i
want to know why why do you want to be
successful in property the more specific
you get
the more likely it's going to happen as
well so if you decide because i want to
become financially free it's like no no
why why do you want to be financially
free because i wanna
uh i wanna quit work why because i'm
tired of being someone's [ __ ]
because i just wanna wake up when i
finish sleeping right
now that's the real specific goal now
you need to just
unravel this like unraveling an onion so
first thing is why get really clear
second thing you need to get around good
people
get around good people i told you
everyone started with a g if you're
around losers
and bums the kind of toxic people that
want to hold you down because it makes
them
feel better you got to go and find new
people you got to get around good people
you got to get out there you got to
start finding people that want you to
win
see if you hang around losers all the
time and people people that have got the
broke mindset toxic people
you gotta cut them don't try and work on
them don't try and change them
just cut them from your life you need
good people good people like this one
see we've been we've been married now
how long amanda five years five years am
i a good person
she's a great person to be around i
would not be successful
in business and anywhere near like i am
if
if i didn't have someone like amanda in
my life good people good business
partner good business coaches
good mentors good people next you've got
to grow
you want your bank to grow you've got to
grow yourself
really important write these down by the
way folks write these down so first
thing is you've got to get goals
second thing is you've got to get good
people around third thing is you've got
to grow grow your knowledge
every single day see the everyone wants
their bank to grow i want to get rich
i want to get more um i want to get more
properties i want to have more money but
they don't want to grow themselves
but your money can only be in an area
that's big enough
let me explain something you want to
have more water in your bucket you need
a bigger bucket
you want to have more money in your life
you got it you got to become a bigger
person
so every day going to grow watch
youtube videos cds podcasts books attend
seminars
and just every day if you're learning
something new
every day what are you reading at the
moment amanda what are you reading
um what are you reading should we find
out okay
here we go reading michelle obama
why do you want to admit to that are you
embarrassed about reading this
embarrassed
you're back is it a good book it is good
you started with me yeah
inspiring it's inspiring why is she why
is amanda reading this
i don't know why why are you reading
this amanda because i think she's a
strong forward and i want to learn from
her experience right you want to grow
yeah you want to grow find people that
are more successful than you are
find people that are more successful
than you are and then learn from them
every day learn something new write it
down and then
over the over the next six months then
look back at everything you've learned
you'll be like holy moly i can't believe
i wrote something down six months ago
like now that's so obvious to me but at
the time it was
aha revelation you want your bank to
grow you've got to grow
next you've got to go you've got to get
yourself out there this is really
important i say
90 percent of success this is number
four 90 of success is just showing
up people say you got so lucky you could
still look i didn't get lucky i just
showed up i was
i was in the right place at the right
time because i went and put myself there
so you want to be successful in property
you can't just expect properties to come
to you you can't just expect
me to come into your living room and
give you a thousand pound check you
can't just expect
um good deals to land on your life
you've got to go actively out there and
look for them number four's go
go go go go go go go sign up for the
webinar
go sign up for the for the viewing go
book review don't think
i can't book a viewing because i haven't
got enough money to buy a house so i'll
wait till i have the money and then i'll
go
never hold off you gotta go go go most
people
you know ready fire no no no
sorry sorry ready aim aim that's me i'm
like ready fire
that's how you gotta be ready aim
aim hey aim and then you retire in your
60s and then when you fight
you can't be that person you know when i
was 17 i got started
i was just like i didn't even i didn't
even say ready aim i didn't even say
ready i was just like fire fire fire go
viewing houses putting offers on stuff
richard branson says
if an opportunity comes along say yes
then figure the details out later
don't worry about this is what i say now
don't worry about the xyz until you've
gone and walked the abc
you just gotta go put yourself out there
go pick up the phone
put offers forward speak to investors
speak to deal sources
and then lastly number five by the way i
hope you're enjoying this video if you
are
drop a like drop a like you need to have
a thumb blue up on this
the weather is so hot here the weather
is so good
i just love paris we literally we've
been to uh
we're kind of going all over europe i
think yesterday we're just bordering on
germany
um where else were we where were we
yesterday amanda or the day before
yesterday belgium
belgium bristles we're in bristol's then
where we were before brussels
and bruce oh bruges oh so good so
so so so good and and and i'm getting
sidetracked right now you just want to
know what this fifth thing is right now
you're one of the fifth thing
you see um the fifth thing really
important is
you gotta focus on money making
activities i said that it was gonna they
were all gonna
end with a start with g okay um generate
income
generate income focus on money making
activities only so many people like i'm
going to get my little website and i'm
going to get my business cards
i'm going to register my company i'll
design my logo and then they'll have
meetings
with their family members to come up
with what their company name is going to
be
forget all that you gotta focus on money
making activities
two things you should be thinking number
one am i growing number two is am i
generating income
are you earning are you learning if
you're not earning or learning forget it
and designing a business card for four
hours
you're not earning anything and you're
not learning anything so scrap it
you've got to be earning or learning
focus on money making activities
so those are the five things are you
ready sweetie pie
yes your hair looks fantastic it looks
doesn't hurt doesn't the hair look
fantastic so
mandy happy happy anniversary i never
thought that i'd be filming myself
kissing
my wife right next to a toilet on a
youtube video
um in front of thousands of people to
potentially see um but i'm happy right
now i'm so happy and you know what
thank god for my property business
because if it wasn't for my property
business i wouldn't be able to afford to
have
an income that means i can go out
traveling and live the life i live
um so i really appreciate what
property's done for me i really
appreciate
those people that have helped me get
started in property that's why i run
this youtube channel you know people say
oh you just won the youtube channel
because you're trying to sell stuff
not really i mean i don't i don't get
paid for running this youtube channel i
hardly run ads on this channel
or you just sell events i'm not even
running events i haven't run an event
for months because of lockdown in corona
but still every single day i'm putting
out a youtube video just because
i bad if i became successful i'd always
share what i learned
with others and help others that way um
so really exciting times
our charities just been registered as
well samuel lee's foundation so oh i'm
excited about that
doing loads and loads of crazy stuff out
in africa digging wells
boreholes um we're working on school
projects at the moment we're gonna be
building a school out in uganda
and honestly it's all thanks to property
so
um yes i've been successful in property
but i'm gonna keep teaching you guys how
to do the exact same thing too so if you
like my channel please do subscribe
smash the like button drop a comment
below and i'll be seeing you in my next
video tomorrow peace out
thanks so much final words of wisdom
amanda
don't stop learning don't stop learning
growing that's it all comes down to the
five juice
see you later guys thank you so much